House of the Dragon episode 4 is about
sex secrets and lies characters make
dramatic emotional choices that may have
unwanted consequences the episode starts
at Storm's end the castle of house
Baratheon we hear thunder rumbling and
wind gusting in the background because
this place is famous for its storms the
winds Roar up from the narrow sea and
slam into the walls of Storm's end
according to Legend Storm's end was
built by Duran God's grief the gods kept
destroying his castles so he rebuilt
them stronger until he finally built
Storm's end a castle strong enough and
Magic enough to withstand the fury of
the Gods the Lord of Storm's end is
boromand Baratheon we saw boroman speak
up for rainy Targaryen at the tournament
in episode 1 because boromand is
rhaenisa's uncle boromand is one of the
great Lords of West ruling the
stormlands just like this Starks rule
the North and the Lannisters ruled the
westerlands rhaenyra is here to find a
husband she's on tour visiting castles
to meet some single men noble families
often have tours like this to find a
marriage partner the books describe one
king meeting a thousand single girls in
one day and is described as a cattle
show because the girls are all lined up
like farm animals so it's not exactly
romantic and rhaenyra is not impressed
by these men this sexy single is from
house dondarian the family of Beric
dondarian in Game of Thrones rhaenyra is
not interested in his dry moat but the
dondarian mentions Rainier's
great-grandmother Queen alisane the wife
of King jahiris who once visited the
dondarian castle blackhaven there
alisane was enthralled by a dandarian
who played sad songs on his harp
blackhaven is also where Kristen Cole is
from Kristen's dad worked for the
dondarians as a steward and Kristen
fought with the dondarians against
dornish incursions the next candidate is
a boy from house Blackwood in the
riverlands the blackwoods are one of the
only families in the South who worship
the old gods like the Starks do the
Blackwood gets insulted by this guy from
house Bracken because the blackwoods and
the brackens have an ancient blood Feud
these families have hated and fought
each other for thousands of years the
blackwoods say that the brackens
poisoned their sacred weirwood tree king
jahiris tried to make peace between
these families but it didn't last at one
point the blackwoods and brackens fight
for control of a pair of hills called
the teats and they argue over whose
boobs the hills are named after are they
Barbara bracken's teats or Missy
Blackwood good states in the main series
the bracken's side with the Lannisters
while the blackwoods support the Starks
and Lord titos Blackwood has an
extremely cool Raven feather cloak so
the blackwoods naturally are fan
favorites among book readers when the
Bracken insults the Blackwood kid
rhaenyra says she likes the Bracken
seems like rhaenyra is attracted to bad
boys and Bullies like her Uncle Damon
Rainier still wears the necklace that
Damon gave her the Blackwood kid has
enough of the bracken's insults so they
fight and the Blackwood kills the
Bracken this is another example of
random violence breaking out when it's
not meant to like those Knights killing
each other at the tournament in episode
1. like rhaenys said there are a lot of
young dumb men in the realm who are
eager to fight for Glory after these
long Decades of Peace some of these
other eligible Bachelors are from houses
Tully Frey and house mud and the mud is
weird because house mud went extinct
about 4 000 years ago the castle of the
mud Kings has been a ruin for so long
that no one remembers its name so this
guy telling rhaenyra he's a mud is kind
of like coming to a first date and
saying you're an Egyptian pharaoh that
said in the books there are some
characters who claim to be descendants
of house mud including the mysterious
Jenny of old Stones who Podrick sings a
song about in Game of Thrones rhaenyra
gets sick of the speed dating and she
heads back to King's Landing even though
she was meant to keep touring for two
more months Daemon Targaryen also
returns to the city after he was off at
War on the stepstones Daemon swoops his
Dragon dangerously over rhaenyra's ship
because Daemon is always desperate for
attention and never misses the chance to
cause some chaos in this episode
daemon's disruptive behavior rocks the
boat both literally and metaphorically
when Daemon Returns the mood at court is
tense because last time Daemon was here
his brother King viserys exiled him and
removed him as heir to the throne then
Daemon practically rebelled against
viserys stealing a dragon egg so now
viserys tries to show strength and
Authority by meeting Damon in the throne
room wearing his crown and holding the
Royal sword blackfyre Daemon presents
the Hammer of the crab feeder who Daemon
killed last episode this is the hammer
that the crab feeder used to nail people
to the beach to die Daemon says that he
copied the crab feeder's brutal
execution method to kill thousands of
triaky men so like when he killed and
mutilated people with his gold cloaks
Daemon again uses violent to create fear
Daemon says to add the crab feeder's
Hammer to the Iron Throne to join the
other weapons of the targaryens defeated
enemies barriston says a similar thing
in Game of Thrones Daemon wears a crown
and calls himself King of the narrow sea
which is the ocean north of the
stepstones it is provocative to call
himself King as though he's the equal of
viserys but then Daemon kneels and gives
up his crown so Daemon makes his
homecoming dramatic and Theatrical
seeking glory and validation for his
accomplishments in the books daemon's
return is even more dramatic Daemon
swoops down on his Dragon during a
tournament to give viserys his crown
viserys forgives daemon's crimes and the
brothers reunite they have a boozy
garden party and talk about their
childhood the books say that viserys
loves Daemon because he remembers the
fun Advent adventurous boy Daemon used
to be and he tries to ignore the violent
selfish man he's become viserys mentions
their mother Alyssa and how she was a
rebel who broke rules Alyssa was a
tomboy kinda like Arya Stark Alyssa had
a crooked broken nose from playing with
a wooden sword and her eyes were two
different colors Alyssa's two favorite
activities were having sex with her
husband Balon and riding her Dragon
melis Alyssa took her son's viserys and
Daemon on Dragon rides when they were
just babies then Alyssa died young from
childbirth complications and now rhaenys
Targaryen rides Alyssa's dragon melis
rhaenyra and Alison start to reconnect
because Alison feels lonely everyone
treats her as a queen not as a friend
she feels trapped in this Castle making
babies all day Allison has now given
birth to a daughter her son second child
after aegon Alison envies rhaenyra's
freedom in getting to choose a husband
Alison didn't get to choose her husband
her father Otto pushed her to be with
viserys rhaenyra had been angry at
Alison for suddenly marrying her dad and
becoming a political rival but now she's
sympathetic and they hold hands again
like they used to this moment of
friendship makes it more painful later
when the relationship is again
threatened rhaenyra speaks with Daemon
in the Valyrian language which is like
their way of speaking secretly and
intimately rhaenyra tells Daemon that
she doesn't want to get married because
she doesn't want to be trapped and
lonely like Alison and she doesn't want
to die in childbirth like her mother
Emma did and like her grandmother Alyssa
died of childbirth and like her other
grandmother dayella also died in
childbirth but Daemon says that you
shouldn't live alone or in fear or else
you'll miss out on life you've got to
take risks break rules and do what you
want daemon's life philosophy sounds
inspiring but Daemon also has a hidden
motivation Daemon hopes to have sex with
rhaenyra and to marry her so he plays
the creepy Uncle giving Rainier wrote
wine telling her that she's matured
rhaenyra asks why Daemon returned what
does he want and it seems that what Dame
once is rhaenyra we see a meeting of the
small Council Thailand Lannister is now
master of ships to replace Corliss and
now rhaenyra is on the council she has a
small Council ball and everything looks
like viserys is finally including
rhaenyra so that she can learn politics
which is super important for the heir to
the throne the council is worried about
Corliss valerion despite Daemon calling
himself the king of the narrow sea it
sounds like a Corliss Now controls the
region and now call us plans to marry
his daughter Elena to the son of the Sea
Lord of braavos braavos is a city in the
East it's where Arya Stark joined the
Faceless Men in Game of Thrones Westeros
usually gets along okay with braavos but
braavos is powerful they're very rich
and have a strong Navy so Otto is
worried that if braavos allies with the
valerians their combined strength could
dominate the narrow sea and potentially
become a threat to the targaryens
Corliss is still angry that viserys
rejected Lena's marriage proposal
Otto says that he learned about
corliss's plans from his brother Hobart
in Old Town which is weird why would
Hobart in Old Town know about Corliss
valerion's plans well old town is the
home of the Citadel of the maesters and
the maesters send the letters between
all the Lords of lesteros so maybe the
hightowers are using the maesters to spy
on Lords across the realm there are
hints in the books of a maester
conspiracy
that night Daemon leaves a message for
rhaenyra it shows her a secret passage
out of a room in the red keep the red
cape was built by King maegor the cruel
and maegor filled the cape with secret
passages hidden doors and steps there
are tunnels to escape the castle in case
of attack there are spaces in the walls
so the child's spies can listen to
conversations after the red keep was
built maegor had all the construction
workers killed so that his secret
passages would stay Secret in Game of
Thrones Varys knows about these passages
and uses them to free Tyrion in Hot D
Damon knows these passages previously we
saw him spying on the small Council from
some hidden space now he uses a passage
to sneak rhaenyra out of the castle to
take her for a night on the town of
freedom and fun disguised in different
clothes and with a hat rhaenyra is freed
from the restrictions of being a
princess she's thrilled to be mistaken
for a boy it's like when Arya pretends
to be a boy and experiences Life as a
common person we see a street performer
doing what looks like fire magic or it
might just be some cheap trick in the
books Melisandre mentions using
flammable powders instead of real magic
but in book 2 Daenerys sees a fire magic
performance and claith says that the
magic is real she says that magic is now
more powerful because Daenerys hatched
dragons it seems that whenever there are
dragons in the world magic is stronger
and at the time of Hot D there are lots
of dragons so this might be an
especially magical time in Westeros
maybe that's why viserys has prophetic
dreams rhaenyra and Daemon see a street
theater show like the one Aya sees in
Brown of us this reveals how the common
people feel about the royal family we
see Daemon in his armor and rhaenyra in
her dress and baby aegon with his Dragon
toy we learned that many common people
want baby aegon to inherit the throne
not rhaenyra because aegon is male while
rhaenyra is a feeble female rhaenyra
says that the common people don't matter
their desires are of no consequence
rhaenyra used those same words no
consequence when she told viserys that
her own desires don't matter rhaenyra
feels like no one cares about her
opinion so why should she care about
anyone else's but we saw in Game of
Thrones that the common people do matter
when they turn against the Lannisters
they start a deadly Riot and support The
Sparrows overthrowing Cersei good
politicians know that to be a successful
ruler you've got to win over the common
people rhaenya steals food from a street
vendor just for the thrill of breaking
rules and she bumps into Harwin strong
the son of Lionel strong who we met last
episode Harwin has joined the gold
cloaks while his family is at court and
Daemon was once the commander of the
gold cloaks so Harwin lets rhaenyra
continue on her secret nighttime
Adventure Daemon takes rhaenyra to a sex
club to show her that sex is not just an
obligation in marriage to produce babies
sex can be for pleasure and passion
these opulent orgies fit with the theme
of decadence this is a time of
prosperity Indulgence and carefree
pleasure like ancient Rome before the
fall while rhaenyra enjoys Fun and
Freedom Queen Ellison is stuck at home
looking cold and lonely Alison gives a
sponge bath to her husband viserys whose
body is falling apart from the infection
that started in his hand in the books
Alison cared for the Old King jeharis
like this when he was sick helping to
bathe and dress him the jester mushroom
claims that Alison also had sex with Joe
Harris there are also rumors that Alison
had sex with viserys before his wife
Emma died and mushroom claims that
Alison lost her virginity to Daemon so
believe it or not the books have even
more secret scandalous sex rumors than
this episode does later viserys and
Alison have sex and Alison gets no
pleasure for her sex is a duty where her
body is used to produce children we see
Alison fidgeting with her fingers a sign
of anxiety and discomfort afterwards she
sees a mouse or rat on the bed which
might represent corruption or sickness
or that viserys has been eating cheese
in bed so while Alison is trapped in a
bad sexual experience rhaenyra explores
the pleasure of her sexuality she and
her uncle Daemon start hooking up and
rhaenyra's into it but then Daemon stops
and just walks away according to the
show's creators Daemon wanted to shock
rhaenyra and he wanted to be in control
of this situation so he was thrown off
when rhaenyra was more passionate and
into this than he was deep down Daemon
knew that using rhaenyra like this was
wrong so suddenly he felt impotent
unable to continue like previously when
he stopped having sex with mazaria so
Daemon leaves rhaenyra feels unsatisfied
so when she gets back to the keep she
playfully flirts with sir Kristen kisses
him and takes off his kingsguard armor
Kristen is reluctant because as a
kingsguard knight he has sworn to ever
have sex and he especially can't have
sex with the princess that's treason in
the books a kingsguard knight called
Terence toyne gets executed for the
crime of having sex with a king's
mistress a night called Luca more strong
a relative of Lionel and Harwin strong
was found to have secretly had three
wives and fathered 16 children while on
the kingsguard so King jahiris had Luca
Moore's penis cut off and sent him to
the Night's Watch so Kristen knows the
danger here but he wants rhaenyra and he
may feel obligated to obey his princess
so Kristen feels deeply conflicted as he
puts down his white kingsguard cloak in
the books a kingsguard knight called
Aris has sex with Ariane Martel Iris
doesn't want to soil his white cloak but
Ariane says there's no harm in love
Knights should be judged for how they
use their sword not for how they used
their [ __ ] so rhaenyra and Kristen have
sex and it feels playful and joyous as
the princess loses her virginity to the
White Knight the next morning rhaenyra
is happy to see Kristen maybe she wants
to continue this dangerous relationship
rhaenyra no longer wears daemon's
necklace Kristen is the one she wants
now but Kristen looks worried and
distant terrified that he'll be found
out and punished the books are full of
these forbidden romances like Jon Snow
and egret and many of these
relationships end in tragedy in the
books the jester mushroom has a very
different version of what happened here
between rhaenyra Kristen and Damon
mushroom claims that rhaenyra originally
wanted Kristen so Daemon gave rhaenyra
sex lessons to teach rhaenyra how to
seduce Kristen but according to mushroom
Chris Kristen rejected rhaenyra and kept
to his kingsguard vows a big theme of
the book Fire and Blood is that the
historians are often wrong and don't
know the real story of what happened
behind closed doors Daemon wakes up
extremely hungover it looks like he
tried to drink enough to forget that he
macked on his niece daemon's ex-lover
mazaria gave him a place to crash it
sounds like Daemon and mazaria haven't
seen each other in years mazaria reveals
that she's no longer a sex worker she's
now a spymaster known as the White Worm
because when rhaenyra leaves the sex
club she's seen by a young boy and that
boy then goes to Otto Hightower and
tells him that rhaenyra hooked up with
Daemon now the boy brings money back to
mazaria payment for the information so
instead of selling sex mazaria now sells
Secrets it's like like how Littlefinger
in Game of Thrones uses brothels both
for selling sex and for spying but why
would mazaria tell Otto about Daemon and
rhaenyra that'll get Daemon in trouble
maybe mazaria wants to hurt Daemon as
revenge for abandoning her and for using
her in his Dragonstone plots
Otto says that mazaria is a trusted
source of information it sounds like
they've been working together for a
while so maybe it was mazaria who told
Otto about daemon's air for a Day speech
in episode 1. maybe mazaria has been
working against Daemon all along then
again Daemon did want to be seen with
Rainier at the sex club he took off
rhaenira's hat so that she'd be
recognized so maybe Daemon wanted
mazaria to tell Otto that he hooked up
with rhaenyra because if people think
that rhaenyra has been devirginized by
Daemon it's more likely that he'll be
allowed to marry rhaenyra but does
mazaria know that Daemon wants Otto to
know the whole Missouri situation is
mysterious so Otto finds out that Daemon
hooked up with rhaenyra and this is a
big opportunity for him politically
because if he can discredit rhaenyra and
Daemon that makes it more likely that
his grandson aegon will become heir to
the throne instead But Otto also knows
that this news will hurt viserys and the
showrunners say that despite all his
plotting Otto does Love viserys and
doesn't want to hurt him nonetheless
Otto tells viserys that his daughter had
sex with his brother and viserys gets
angry he accuses Otto of trying to
undermine rhaenyra to support aegon
which is true viserys finally starts to
realize that his trusted hand is corrupt
just like his actual hand is corrupt and
infected and Alison overhears this
conversation so then Alison confronts
rhaenyra about her having sex with Damon
Alison is angry because a princess
having sex out of wedlock is seen as a
terrible scandalous dishonor not only to
rhaenyra but to the whole royal family
rhaenyra losing her virginity makes her
a less desirable wife which could make
it harder to make a good marriage
Alliance and incest and adultery are
considered sins by the faith of the
seven and Alison is a devout believer
some people like Daemon don't care about
these rules he thinks targaryens can do
whatever they want but Alison lives by
these rules she is trapped in these
rules so maybe Alison feels envious that
rhaenyra gets to do what she wants while
Alison is trapped in a lonely marriage
with viserys Alison may also just feel
scared that if Rainier is punished and
sent away Alison could lose her only
friend when rhaenyra is faced with this
dangerous allegation she lies she swears
on her mother's memory that Daemon
didn't touch her which
totally did making a false oath like
this is pretty bad in Westeros
especially in front of a weirwood tree
rhaenyra and Alison don't believe in the
old God's religion but symbolically
there's a sense that the old gods see
rhaenyra's lie how will Alison react if
she finds out about this lie Allison and
rhaenyra's relationship is probably the
longest and most intimate relationship
in both their lives they grew up
together they love each other so secrets
between them can leave deep painful
wounds later Alison tells viserys that
she believes that rhaenyra is innocent
she sticks up for a friend which makes
it all the more tragic that rhaenyra
lied viserys confronts Daemon angry at
him for having sex with rhaenyra of
course Daemon didn't have sex with
rhaenyra but Daemon lets viserys believe
that he did because if rhaenyra is no
longer a Virgin It be harder to marry
her off so Daemon says heal marry
rhaenyra and this is a political move by
Daemon because rhaenyra is heir to the
throne as her husband Daemon could
potentially rule Westeros so it looks
like this was daemon's plan all along to
use rhaenyra to get the throne and to
piss off viserys Daemon resents viserys
for exiling him for not making him hand
for not giving him the love and
validation that he wants Daemon succeeds
in pissing off viserys but he fails to
get rhaenyra as wife viserys says no
partly because Daemon is already married
to his estranged wife Reya and while the
faith has accepted Targaryen incest the
faith is not okay with polygamy viserys
Exiles Daemon again tells him to go back
to his wife in The Veil and to never
come back then viserys confronts
rhaenero and he tells her that her
personal desires aren't as important as
the strength of House Targaryen because
of aegon the conqueror's dream his
prophecy that the targaryens will save
the world from the white walkers aegon
wrote a message on his Valyrian steel
dagger that only appears when it's in
fire like the one ring and it says from
my blood come the prince that was
promised and his will be the song of ice
and fire so what does that mean the
prince that was promised or Azor ahai is
a prophesied hero the chosen one who
will lead the war against the white
walkers in the Game of Thrones show
Melisandre thinks Stannis is the prince
that was promised then she thinks it's
Jon Snow then she thinks that both Jon
and Daenerys have a role to play so then
Jon and Daenerys help in the battle when
Arya kills the night King using aegon's
dagger in the books the prophecy stuff
is more complicated it's said that the
hero will use a burning sword called
lightbringer there are themes of
sacrifice that might connect to John
killing Daenerys The Song of Ice and
Fire is a line from book two when
Daenerys has a vision of her brother
rhaegar rhaegar says that his son is the
prince that was promised and his is the
Song of Ice and Fire rhaegar does change
his mind a lot about who the prince that
was promised is but there are lots of
hints that rhaegar's son Jon Snow is
probably the chosen one Jon is the son
of an icy Stark and a fiery Targaryen
making him a song or Son Of Ice And Fire
Ned Stark promises to protect Jon which
makes Jon literally a prince that was
promised so it looks like in the books
Jon will probably play a bigger role in
defeating the white walkers he won't
just shout at a dragon while Arya saves
the day but prophecies are ambiguous and
the book series isn't finished so it's
still a mystery how the books will end
the point of all this is that the
Targaryen Throne is a huge
responsibility it's not just about
personal desires it's about protecting
the bloodline that will save the world
so rhaenyra should not undermine their
strength and stability by rooting her
uncle viserys says that the old king
jeheris would have disinherited rhaenyra
for this because joharis had similar
trouble with his daughter Sarah when
Sarah had secret scandalous sex jiharis
was Furious and said that Sarah was no
longer his daughter and Sarah ran off to
a brothel in the east of course it's
very unfair that women aren't allowed
sexual Freedom while men can generally
root who they want without consequence
but viserys says that the time for
childish Rebellion is over he says
rhaenyra will marry Lane valerion the
Sun and heir of Lord Corless and the
rider of the Dragon sea smoke marriage
to lanor will renew the Targaryen
alliance with the powerful valerions to
bring new strength and unity to the
royal family rhaenyra reluctantly agrees
to the marriage on the condition that
viserys removes Otto as hand of the king
rhaenyra knows that Otto is plotting
against her trying to make aegon air
instead of her so viserys agrees to
remove his corrupt hand viserys
confronts Otto and talks about his
father Balon Targaryen the husband and
brother of Alyssa Prince Balon the brave
was a warrior he rode the Great Dragon
Vega and wielded the Valyrian steel
sword Dark sister now used by Daemon
Balon became hand of the king to his
father King jiharis and in the books
Balon served as hand for over a year he
was effective and popular with Lords and
common folk but then Balon died of a
burst belly which might mean
appendicitis so Otto Hightower became
the new hand now viserys seems to
suspect that Otto murdered Balon with
poison or something so that Otto could
become hand viserys is now deeply
suspicious of Otto because viserys has
realized that Otto has been manipulating
him for years it was Otto's plan for
Alison to hook up with viserys
exploiting viserys's grief for his dead
wife to serve Otto's ambition to get his
daughter married to the king viserys can
no longer trust Otto so he removes him
as hand though the high Towers remain a
powerful and ambitious family Grand
maester Melos brings rhaenyra some Moon
tea this is the westerosi version of a
morning after pill uh plan b or plan T
so if rhaenyra got pregnant last night
this will end the pregnancy to prevent
any Troublesome Royal bastards being
born Melos says that viserys sent
rhaenyra the tea but maybe melos's buddy
Otto told him to do it
Otto doesn't want rhaenyra birthing any
sons who might claim the throne ahead of
aegon Melos leaves and the episode ends
so we don't know for sure if rhaenyra
drinks the tea maybe Kristen Cole's
bastard son is growing inside her the
last words in this episode are unwanted
consequences because the characters make
emotional decisions that might come back
to bite them Daemon hooks up with
rhaenyra rhaenyra hooks up with Kristen
and lies to Alison viserys rejects
Daemon and Otto mazaria spies for Otto
and this Blackwood kills this Bracken
all these acts could lead to bigger
conflicts later on King viserys is
getting sicker and weaker each episode
and when he dies there'll be multiple
conflicting claimants to his throne
there's a shot of rats on a dragon skull
like scavengers feasting on the corpse
of House Targaryen the character's
choices now will shape the conflicts to
come
if you want to know more about Balon the
Brave and Alyssa and Sarah and jaharas
the full story is told in Fire and Blood
chapters 10 and 11. you can get fire and
blood or any other audiobook for free
right now at audible.com ASX sign up for
a Premium Plus trial membership and you
get an audiobook to keep even if you
cancel the trial you can get any Game of
Thrones book or Lord of the Rings or
Dune membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audiobooks and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com ASX or text ASX to
500-500 thanks for watching please like
And subscribe and check out the podcasts
linked below thanks to the patrons
including Maggie Brockway Tom Crow
kustkamp Conrad Juan Camilla Ruiz
Theodore Zen Matthew slip and Chuck and
Noob Foo cheers